1er janvier 2015 avait pas de la ravine
blanche dans la fondation avon à saint
pierre l'ambiance est festive et
dansante
tout le monde met la main à la pâte pour
les préparatifs
le couvert et bien pu dresser les
amuse-bouches sont bientôt prêt ce midi
des résidents et l'équipe médico social
sac la nouvelle année c'est important de
commandes est en bonne santé l'essentiel
oui ta famille un peu à voir mais j'ai
enfin voir mais enfin les choux va ça va
être vraiment une belle journée
aujourd'hui ils vont vraiment pouvoir
revoir des choses qui sont différents
montrer que le bas c'est une nouvelle
année qui commence et qu'on est avec eux
qui sont pas tout seuls en fait
et ben voilà on est là pour ça donc on
donne de son temps
même le premier de l'an l'ehpad hagen 90
résidents lieu certains sont concernés
la maladie
et puis en charge dans une unité
protégée c'est ici dans cette unité
baptisée cristal de roche que la fed est
organisée contre ce qui permet à
l'ensemble des résidents de se retrouver
pour quoi faire la fête aujourd'hui ici
parce que justement d'avoir
des moments de fête importante comme
nous
le jour de l'an le 1er janvier ça leur
permet d'avoir des gardes et des repères
aussi sur le temps et
perdant année qui leur rappellent aussi
où ils sont ce qui se passe et qui
et qu'ils ont
encore des gens qui s'occupent
présents
et l'amour
la bonne humeur est au rendez vous tout
est prêt et résidente passer à table et
partager ce repas de fête
c'est vrai mais c'est bien déjà ce jeudi
et là on arrive en 2015 qu'est ce que ça
veut dire beaucoup
mais voilà vous cette année là aussi qu
on voudrait pour cette année là encore
carrière à une personne ou la chaleur le
bruit les bavardages certains résidents
ont préféré l'éviter et rester dans leur
chambre mode ne les a pas oubliés et
apporte une petite coupe trinquer à la
saint sylvestre
tu veux que je t'aide ou
voilà en 2015 en tout cas ma chérie on
est le premier jour de l'année
depuis des années annie ifad en membrane
et ouais bon aller où un tueur lamelle
pour elle la nouvelle année est un
moment qui reste important
on a mangé une nouvelle année et puis on
est arabe orne beaucoup de forces dans
le coeur du genre
quand même vous la petite coupe de
champagne et sourire de mode ça
mme bachelot car beaucoup pour atteindre
un gros bisou
ma petite chérie à ça
c'est le moment
que m
j aimerais à force d'être auprès des
résidents jour après jour on crée un
lien dans les soins dans les activités
et c'est un lien qui est justement pour
les personnes qui sont en perte de
repères
au niveau temps et l'espace
une personne qui soit un lien pour cet
important donc
delors justement de faire la fête avec
eux aussi et c'est important quand on
est là de mettre en place des activités
avec aussi les autres résidents qui sont
présents ça leur part mire se rappeler
qu'à de la vie c'est pour ça que si on
travaille en civil de temps en temps
pour dire qu'on n'est pas là que pour
faire des soins on est là aussi pour
autre chose pour
pour un sourire pour pour une discussion
pour des choses différentes en fait on
fait pas que du soin pour du soin et son
ami l'ehpad est un établissement qui est
lourdement médicalisée comme tout à
l'heure je lui disais mais également
aussi c'était mieux de vie le devis ou
libourne s'amuser et c'est la raison
pour laquelle devant organiser le plus
de manifestations et d'animation
possible de manière à égayer le
quotidien des personnages de la gaieté
au quotidien c'est l'accompagnement que
proposent les équipes de l'ehpad un
savant mélange de savoir faire et de
savoir être